star wars visions va être une
passionnante série d'anthologies animées à venir
sur disney plus en septembre l'
animation japonaise a inspiré beaucoup de
gens chez lucasfilm au fil des ans, nous avons
adoré l'idée de voir star wars
exprimé de cette manière
chacun de ces studios que nous
approchés, nous avons trouvé des fans inconditionnels de Star
Wars, ils avaient tous une histoire qu'ils
voulaient  jouer
gros et audacieux romantique et
drôle comique
[Musique]
étranger
nous essayons d'avoir un sentiment rétro vintage
nous ne pouvions pas ignorer l'
influence des astéroïdes les gens nous aiment les ennuis
[Musique]
mon nous nous sentons tellement chanceux de travailler
avec ces cinéastes
il y a tellement d'opportunités de refléter la
narration japonaise dans un
univers de
star wars les visions de star wars sont complètement
différentes de tout le reste dans la
narration de star wars le public le fera  tomber
amoureux
[Musique]
toi